l'homme est un animal mais c'est un
animal capable de s'élever au-dessus de
son instinct et de dire je suis plus
qu'un animal mon instinct me constitue
c'est un allié de ma survie mais quand
ma survie n'est plus en jeu quand mon
existence ne se résume plus à une lutte
pour la survie je deviens être humain un
être capable de transformer le monde
de partager le fruit de mes conquêtes de
protéger les faibles des prédations des
forts je deviens un être soucieux du
groupe car s'il est de notre devoir de
suivre les lois de la nature gardons à
l'esprit que la nature a fait de nous
des êtres capables de donner et auons le
mot capable
d'aimer